hey guys dr. Berg here in this video I'm
going to share with you how much protein
we really need okay
so if you look this up you know they
will say that you need point eight grams
of protein times your body weight per
day okay honestly I think that's way way
too much
now even say if you're an athlete you
would need one or one and a half times
your body weight in the amount of
protein that can go with like 300 grams
of protein per day so here's the problem
I'm seeing in a clinical practice every
day for the last 26 years okay people
are doing way too much protein they
don't need as much as they think so I
think you would need half of the rec
requirements okay so I weigh about 193
so I should have about 0.4 times my body
weight so I need about 78 grams of
protein per day now what does that mean
78 grams it's about 26 grams per meal
all right and I think the average person
needs between like 25 and 35 grams of
protein because anything more than that
tends to turn into sugar now that's a
generality but it's it tends to be true
so when it turns into sugar it spikes
insulin okay so so 26 grams per meal
which would be about like 5 ounces so if
I was having a piece of like a burger
patty it'd be like a deck of a car cards
okay or like it'd be 4 eggs and that's
what I have for breakfast or not quite a
full chicken breast but maybe 3/4 of a
chicken breast so it's not that much
protein when I consume too much protein
I find my sleeping isn't quite right
protein has a lot of phosphorus
phosphorus is a stimulant so if you're
doing all this protein protein snacks
all day you're not going to sleep that
well you need some a lot more vegetables
to wine you down with all the the
minerals that calm your body so
phosphorus is like an accelerator other
minerals like calcium magnesium from the
vegetables tend to calm you down so I
like a good amount of this and just a
little bit of protein seems to work
really good but you don't need as much
protein as you think there are variables
so there's exceptions to the rule so
here's the variables
everyone if you're younger you can
tolerate more protein if you're older
you can't the liver actually is the
organ that helps break down protein so
if you have a bad liver a fatty liver
because you have a gut
you're not going to digest a lot of
protein so just a little bit also the
strength of your digestive acids most
people have low acids in their stomach
and then they have heartburn so if they
would have apple cider vinegar they
could start to increase the acid and
digest more protein people that get gas
especially on the protein what that
means is they don't have enough stomach
acids so the lower the acid the less you
can digest protein okay
exercise now if you're exercising and
you're breaking down proteins muscle
you're going to need a little more
protein all right that's just the fact
so if you're sedentary you're not going
to eat as much protein it's very very
simple the more stressed you are the
more protein you will need but typically
the average person even if they work out
they don't need a lot of protein so but
this is something that is kind of some
of you have to test out with your body
and play around with the numbers to get
your exact amount so you might want to
start with 0.4 grams times your body
weight and then play around and see how
you feel okay see if you recover see if
you feel good see if you sleep see if
you're not bloated after you eat and
then maybe you increase it you know
because some people need a little bit
more some people need a little less okay
now the other thing is that too much
protein raises a hormone called insulin
and that keeps you fat so you can
actually get fat by too much protein
especially if it's lean protein they
found that whey protein because it's
really lean low-fat or other types of
lean protein spike insulin more than
fatty protein like things like even
bacon or sausage things like that so
that has a neutral effect on insulin so
when you consume protein don't try to go
for the lean get the full fat in there
as well so when I eat chicken I have the
skin on it when I have beef I have all
the fat I don't get it lean I just don't
because it's going to spike insulin a
little bit more than you would think
okay then also if you add sugar to the
protein like I was this weekend I was an
in town Pennsylvania at this market I
was just observing people eat massive
amounts of protein with massive amounts
of sugar and they have the sugar and the
cake and the sweet and this and that
what they're doing is they're spiking
insulin when you add sugar to protein
you greatly aggravate and exaggerate the
insulin spike so that's like a deadly
combination you don't want to add the
bun to the meat or the ketchup or the
sugar to meat especially like the even
the barbecued ribs there's ways you can
make it without sugar but those are just
some interesting points about protein in
how that will mess up your your weight
as well okay so I hope that helped and
go ahead and write your comments below I
will see you in the next video